today we celebrate his 2000th managerial
game congrats to buddy today prior to
the ball game mark gugliomo the senior
vice president and general manager of
petco park after 36 years where the
padres is retiring at a very nice
ceremony for googs right before the game
today throughout the first pitch and a
good one as well we'll certainly miss
him around the ballpark every day he has
been here a long time dating back course
with bud black's time as the manager for
mark gugliomo congratulations on a great
career we will miss you with the padres
oh he's one of the best on the mound for
the padres today ryan weathers 11th
start for the 21 year old second career
appearance first career start against
the rockies in this first half finale
229 opponent's batting average there's a
four-seamer slider
a two-seamer and a change-up that's a
line shot to center field stay hot elias
diaz
and
you know he's not afraid to make a move
he's made an abundance of them
on the ground to third base machado to
second for one on the first for two
there's your double play
around the horn it goes five four three
on the inning ending dp padres are
coming up from san diego john gray who
like seemingly everyone else in that
rocky's rotation has thrown the ball
exceptionally well especially since
coming off the il and his three starts
he's want to know what the 265 just five
earned runs
well he got blown away there at 96.
great start for gray
2-0 pitch
and a ground ball down the first faith
line that is fair into the corner
heading for second is chronoworth taking
it out as blackman quillerworth he's
thinking three he's headed for third
he'll get there standing
third triple of the season for jake
but still i think it's just a good piece
of hitting for john doesn't matter he's
going to come right back up
get the fly out yep on a plus fastball
so a good start for john great despite
tripled by cronenworth we'll go to the
second no score in san diego
[Music]
one-two pitch
and a swing and a miss elevated to
strike him out 94 on the fastball first
strike out of the day for ryan weather
and we know about the high fastball
these days in baseball a lot of hitters
will fish after that and this is evident
here up and in
fly ball to shallow center ducking back
is cronenworth
still going and he'll get there to make
the catch
[Applause]
there's a liner into the center field
off the bat at trent grisham
all the way back to the track of the
wall grisham his second base with a
stand-up double to begin the bottom of
the second inning
at third hosmer at second meyers at
first nobody out in the padres second
inning
on the ground right side hanson was the
second for one on to first that's two
run scores as grisham comes in the back
door from third
padres are on the board but i think john
gray will take that exchange on the dp
now weathers will have to
use that good pick off move to keep
hampton close we had a bag last night 13
out of 15 and the bunt by gray is pushed
towards first weathers picks it up
trying to tag him they collided weathers
lost the ball and now he's down in a
heap in foul territory and weathers is
holding his right knee kind of rolling
around in front of the coaches box at
first base
this is really disturbing it really
stinks for the padres as he's going
forward he plants that right leg trying
to apply the tag there and he goes down
immediately goes to his right knee the
outside of his right knee
writhing in pain there then uh assisted
off
gosh darn it hate to see that and into
this game is pierce johnson now take it
off for third noticing
and the tag is there two down
hampson took off for third pierce
johnson noticed steps off throws him out
in the air down the left field line fan
with a long run towards the line will
get there to make the catch
and ends the inning so what appeared to
be a promising inning for the rockies
they get nothing it's one nothing padres
[Applause]
one two pitch swing and a miss went
breaking ball there and got tatis jr for
out number two it's one of those uh
outings for chris paddock to wear coming
out of the bullpen just let it eat just
go right after him first career relief
appearance for chris
swinging a miss and striking out is
stories two rockies down in the fourth
is up a fly ball to deep right did cj
get enough you bet tied up the ball game
for crone is 12th of the year and it's a
1-1 affair i'd say what it's hard to hit
a ball out to right field to san diego
as a right-handed hitter
but then to do it on a changeup cj gets
a change up at 86 miles an hour and
takes it out to right center field the
pitcher weathers grounded out to hold
the padres to one run right there
one-two pitch swing and a miss got him
chasing on a pitch down and away
strikeout for john gray number three on
the day grisham and myers aboard
in the air
left field playable for rymel
he's got it and two men are left on the
fourth so we march on to the fifth the
rockies one at the padres one
tapia and diaz scheduled a bat nine one
and two here in the fifth
and that is strike three gray strikes
out
third strikeout for chris paddy
swinging advance and he strikes out
trevor story
for the second time that's 4k is for
paddock halfway through tied at one
that 98 mile an hour fastball did not
miss tommy pham
upset not at the call he's upset with
himself 102 fuentes
down to third and machado with a bobble
but he's going to get a tag out
wow crunch just kind of ran into that
out yeah
that was weird
shadow couldn't feel it cleanly but
that's somebody to tag out in the
neighborhood so he did
running into the out
you watch a lot of times it's wow that
was just flat out nasty yeah it started
as a strike and by the time cronin were
swung at it it was closer to hitting him
what a slider
here's the 1-2 and he's got him on a
slider but he struck out three out of
the last four he's getting stronger yeah
back-to-back pitches too with the slider
strikeout 1-1 score in the seventh
stamen with the breaking pitch and
owings hits it high in the air center
field going back grisham at the wall and
gone
chris owings with his
first of the year and the rockies take
the lead two to one
chris owings the pinch-hit home run so
the rockies lead 2-1 they love to get
buddy a
victory that's a great catch by tapia
well done as he robs eric hosmer
hope to get him a victory in game number
two thousand
chasing on in relief of gray who was
marvelous and rymel tapia with a
beautiful catch now tapia tapio for four
slowly hit to second adams is out high
throw himself coming home he'll score it
should have been an inning ending double
play
that would have been the third out and
it would have prevented the rockies from
scoring instead it's an error and the
rockies get
that extra run here we go
osmar at second two outs rockies up
three to one here's the 3-2
he's got him strike three ball game over
and in the 2000 managerial game for
buddy black he gets a victory against
his old club